now this is an odd thing the way that
characters come back Dolores Umbridge
what is the connection between Dolores
Umbridge and Harry Potter and
coronavirus you tell me well media or
anything so I've no idea what's going on
well on Twitter there's lots of these
tweets if we followed Laura's um
purchase proclamations nobody would get
coronavirus did she bring in the social
decision did you invent it yes
absolutely she did and and and all for
the better I feel yeah coronavirus is
the Dolores Umbridge of the world right
now
also coronavirus had a name it would be
Dolores Umbridge oh okay okay I'm gonna
keep a low profile on that actually
social distancing for you as Dolores
Umbridge do people kind of scatter out
of your way in supermarkets anyway
absolutely do anyway so I've never I've
never touched I've never touched anyone
in industry and I've been working around
who are you you and I get to step away
step away and they do
[Music]
you